[Music]
just for the record there's not one
person in this group that I would chose
him for this type of mission they are
all too reckless government has killed
hundreds of families many more will die
if something is not born what do you
know about what's happening in Ethiopia
it's another bloody genocide but nobody
gives a [ __ ] because it's an effort well
your Prime Minister decided to give a
[ __ ] the red sea diving resort it's a
hotel we can use to smuggle the refugees
through Sudan to Israel that's very
clear
if this goes wrong
we all be hanging from cranes
BC best cover we could ask for
place is on the way home
they're still hundreds crossing the
border every week we are watching you
yes with our country's tenure box the
mission is an order for us I promise
this is not a mission for me this is my
life
they're executing dissidents it's
revolution we must leave now we dine
you're sick you're starving
the roadblock full speed ahead you are
crazy
you're a lucky guy
but when the luck runs out you gotta
have a plan and you never have one
we need no one behind
oh just refugees aren't me
[Music]